اهلا بكم اهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه الان وصلت سفينه جلاله الملك ابها
هذه السفينه التي علمتنها عدد كبير من
الرعايه كما يظهر لنا امامكم على الصوره
يبدا القوات البحريه السعوديه بتجهيز
السلم الخاص لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى يستطيعوا
النزول على ارض قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده نتحدث انه تم اجلاء هؤلاء الرعايه
من ميناء بورت السودان الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في جده في رحله استغرقت
قرابه عشر ساعات نتحدث انه 200 واثنى عشر
راكبا على متن هذه السفينه من اثنين عشره
جنسيه اختلفت الجنسيات وتنوعت بين
افغانستان وبين السودان وبين الفلبين
والجزر القمر وسريلانكا وكذلك اوكرانيا
ومن بريطانيا وسوريا وامريكا وكذلك من
مدغشقر نتحدث انه علامتنا هذه السفينه 41
مواطن السعودي وكذلك نتحدث عن وجود
سبعه اشخاص من رعايه اوكرانيا تم اجلائهم
من ميناء بورت سودان الى مقاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه وهذه الرحله رقم 14 منذ بدا
عمليات الاجلاء نتحدث عن وجود اثنا عشر
اثني عشر
سفينه بحريه السعوديه تابع القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه وكذلك نتحدث عن
السفينتين مدنيه وتسمى بسفينه امان التي
قامت خلال يومين الماضيه بنقل عدد كبير من
الرعايه طوال منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء كان
قد اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان
اعداد من تم اجلائهم من السودان الى جده
تحديدا عبر ميناء جد الاسلامي وعبر
القاعده الجويه وكذلك عبر قاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه مع هذه الرحله بلغ عددهم
5409 عشره شخص وتروعت الجنسيات وتنوعت
كذلك الاعمار ايضا نتحدث عن اكثر من 100
او ينتبون لاكثر من 100 من ضمنهم مواطنين
سعوديين وعربيين ومن الخليج وكذلك من
اوروبا ومن فريق ومن افريقيا واختلفت
الجنسيات كما ذكرنا من مئه جنسيه على متن
هذه السفينه هنالك خمسه حالات طبيه واحده
منها سوف يتم نقلها الى اقرب مستشفى من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ليتم بتقديم
العلاج اللازم لها علامات من هذه السفينه
فرق الطبيه لتقديم الاسعافات الاوليه
والتعامل مع الحالات الصحيه التي تم
اجلاؤها من ميناء بورتسودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه قبل وصول هذه السفينه
تواجد عدد كبير من السفراء والقناصر
لهؤلاء الرعايه لاستقبالهم وكذلك وجود عدد
من ممثليه وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وعدم
القطاعات الامنيه لاستقبال هؤلاء الرعايه
وانهاء كافه اجراءات دخولهم الى اراضي
السعوديه ومنحهم تاشيره دخول لمده شهر
قامت بمنحها وسوف تقوم بمنحها من قبل
بمنحها من قبل المديريه
للجوازات تاشيره استثنائيه لهؤلاء الرعايه
نظرا للظرف الانسان الذي اهم عليه ايضا
نتحدث انه طوال هذه الرحله هنالك خدمات
كبيره تقدم لهؤلاء الرعايه من ضمنها توفير
غرف النوم خاصه لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك
توفير الاعاشه وكافه الخدمات اللوجستيه
والصحيه لهؤلاء الرعايه في ظل الظروف
الصعبه التي عاشوا تفاصيلها طوال الايام
الماضيه هنالك في السودان في الخرطوم
تحديدا او حتى في الولايات التابعه
للخرطوم في ظل اشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات
الدعم السريع وبين الجيش السوداني دقائق
محدوده وبسيطه وسوف يتم تركيب هذا السلم
وانزال هؤلاء الرعايه ونقلهم عبر اسطول من
الحافلات الى مقرات سكن قامت بتخصيصها
السلطات السعوديه سلطان هل من معلومات عن
اي رحلات بحريه مجدوله في 48 ساعه المقبله
ستستقبلها قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في
جده المعلومات
بالفعل لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء مستمره من
السودان جوا وبحرا لتحدثنا الى قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه او عبر ميناء جدا اسلامي او
حتى كذلك عبر قاعده او الجسر الجوي الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده من
المتوقع وصول غدا سفينه امان السفينه
التجاريه المدنيه السعوديه وعلى متنها
اعداد تلامس الالفين شخص باختلاف جنسياتهم
لاسيه من هذه السفن المدنيه تستطيع
استيعاب اكبر الاعداد من الرعايه الذين
سوف يتم اجلائهم من من بورت السودان الى
جده هذه السفره البحريه التابع للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه تستطيع استيعاب
اعداد محدوده نظرا انه هذه السفينه مخصصه
للعمليات العسكريه وغيرها لكن صخره
السلطات السعوديه والقوات البحريه
السعوديه كافه السفر البحريه والمدنيه
لاجلاء هؤلاء الرعايه بشكل مستمر منذ بدء
النزاعات هنالك في السودان من ميناء
بورسودان نقلا قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه
واقعه الملك عبد الله الجويه وكذلك عبر
ميناء جده الاسلامي نؤكد من عمليات اللجنه
مستمره كما اعلن او صرح لنا العميد التركي
المالكي المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الدفاع
يوم امس للعربيه والحدث بان عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره من قبل الحكومه السعوديه
للرعايه باختلاف جنسيتهم واعمارهم وفئاتهم
الى مدينه جده بحسب الوضع الراهن في
السودان نشاهد الان علامه او على سطحه على
متن هذه السفينه الرعايه يستعدون للنزول
الى قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه نتحدث عن
جنسيات متعدده
وفق معلوماتك اذا سمحت لي كم كم تستغرق
الرحله من الوقت يعني
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بشكل اجمالي
وهل يعني الرحله من السفينه الى سفينه
تختلف من حيث الوقت ام لا
بالفعل السفن البحريه التابع للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه تستغرق قرابه من
العشر ساعات الى 12 ساعه من ميناء بورت
سودان وصولا الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
فيما يتعلق بالسفر المدنيه الضخمه
والكبيره قد تاخذ وقت اطول سيما العدد
العدد اكبر وكذلك سفينه ضخمه فقد تستغرق
وقت اطول لفئه لعمليات النقل من ميناء
بورت سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده ايضا نشير ان عمليات الاجلاء لا تزال
مستمره بشكل ملحوظ منذ بدل منذ بدل اسمه
هنالك في السودان لكن الخدمات المقدمه اذا
اشرنا اليها علامتنا هذه السفينه نحن قد
قمنا بمرافقه احدى السفن البحريه السعوديه
خلال اليومين الماضيه واستغرقت قرابه
العشر ساعات وتم تقديم كافه الخدمات
اللوجستيه والصحيه والطبيه لهؤلاء الرعايه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات